be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so it's like 1:15 in the morning
right now and I am totally wired and I
guess this is potato been working out
all the time so I have like energy all
the time like I can't sleep I feel like
I'm gonna go upstairs and lay down after
I record this and just crash out for
like ten hours which kind of sucks
anyway I want to be a little bit
interesting here I want to try my hand
at recording or at least covering the
beginning of J michael Straczynski 'he's
run on thor we're gonna cover this first
issue as a separate video because
there's a lot to explain and also kind
of a test thing right if you guys dig it
we'll probably just go ahead and cover
each individual issue over the course of
the week or over the course of however
long it takes us to get through all 12
so 12 days but for those of you guys who
are who got in like Jason Aaron Sport
which is to say like Thor god of thunder
with like Gor the god butcher and all
that kind of stuff those of you guys who
were reading Thor right now and the idea
that like you had the events of siege on
Asgard and so on and so forth all that
starts here right like this all starts
with J michael Straczynski drun and this
all comes off the tails of Ragnarok
right we talked about that story before
and in fact we covered it you'll find
the whole Ford playlist down in the
description but the idea behind Ragnarok
was to basically remove Thor from the
landscape and one of the lot of people
don't know if you go back and you read
the old interviews from from casada and
all them the idea was to actually kill
off Thor and to remove him from the
landscape for a while ultimately they
didn't dream on cruises and esters in
ski brought him back a few years later
with really with this story but the idea
here was to basically bring Thor back in
a way that would kind of return his
character back to his roots right that
fell in line with what it is an editor
and editor-in-chief Joe Quesada wanted
to do right like take all the characters
and put them back to the way they used
to be spider-man goes back to being
single the Avengers go back to being the
the kind of classic mainstays of
Marvel's sort of coming together on a
single team hence the reason why we got
the New Avengers while Brian Michael
Bendis the x-men their entire population
was reduced down to 198 so it was a
wholesale reshuffling of Marvel across
the board and Thor was no exception and
so what this does as it initially sort
of picks up was seemingly with Thor kind
of recounting his life right the things
that he's known the success he's had
fighting alongside the warriors 3
ultimately becoming Donald Blake falling
in love with SIF and then going on and
eventually falling in love with Jane
Foster only lose Jane Foster different
things along those lines but it's
basically kind of you know going over
his life and the struggles he's dealt
with the fact that he basically faced
off against these various forces during
Ragnarok died it's just kind of a solid
run over but it's the way for J michael
Straczynski to say hey guys here's
what's going on with Thor so the big
question that people probably have is
what has there been doing this entire
time but I can tell you exactly what
Thor has been doing this entire time
Thor's been using Skillshare hashtag
sponsored video so Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
with more than 25,000 classes in design
business and more including photography
and filmography I especially dig the
photography and filmography parts of the
of the website because I've been doing
like photos I've been taking pictures
for a long long time
but I always knew there was always more
to learn and so like being on Skillshare
and like learning all these things and
photographers do in order to get like
really really good shots street
photography portrait photography
different things like that it's actually
helped to blow up my personal Instagram
I am rob Jefferson it's basically been
blowing it up which is pretty awesome
but in order to get you guys started
skills share is giving away a free 2
month unlimited access trial to the
first 500 people who click the link in
the description and after that it's only
around 10 bucks a month so if you guys
want to beef up your photography game
your filmography game if you guys want
to learn how to make videos like me go
to Skillshare click the link down in the
description and they will get you there
but regards to the story what's going on
with Thor is that he's not really alive
but he's not really dead he's in what's
called the void now in my mind the way I
looked at this was that under normal
circumstances Thor would have done right
like he would have gone to where hellah
was Riley he would have gone to that
like afterlife more or less a father
would have gone to Valhalla to be honest
because of the fact that he was such an
honorable warrior that kind of a thing
it looked like in and for I recall I
think Rosinski had no forum post and he
made where he was talking about this and
he said the idea was that the reason why
Thor didn't go there is because of the
fact that Donald Blake anchored him to
life right because when it comes to the
Donald Blake through a relationship but
I want to talk about this because I feel
like this is something that really
confuses a lot of people and now's as
good of a time as any to really bring
this up this whole idea here with with
Donald Blake basically having this
conversation with Thor as Donald Lakes
literally going about and just kind of
talking about things heading toward his
destination grabbing Thor's hammer
different things like that
what he does is he basically says we're
the same person and and the reason why
you see Thor saying things like well
there was an Odin spell that split us
apart and and like that doesn't it
doesn't work like that anymore is
because when you go back and you read
the old four stories when he first
appeared back in 1962 right so the old
journey into mystery stories what you
got was was essentially a byproduct of
the time right which is to say ever
since Action Comics issue number one in
1938 in the introduction of Superman as
the first superhero of alter egos had
been a
of comic books right they were a
mainstay they were staple the concept of
an alter-ego was tried and true
something that you didn't really mess
with too much and so we got that with
Thor right you go back and you read the
old stories you had this guy named
Donald Blake and Donald Blake was this
this doctor who had kind of a limp of
sorts he had a how does a handicap and
he was hanging out with Jane Foster he
was in love with and she didn't really
return his affection and there was like
this weird alien invasion thing kind of
going on so he runs and he hides in a
cave and he ends up ends up finding a
stick and he gets frustrated he smacks a
stick on a rock and the stick turns into
Milner and he turns into Thor with with
the old Stan Lee and Jack Kirby comics
the way those were written it was not
Thor who was turning him to Donald Blake
in the other way around it was basically
this idea that like Donald Blake was
channelling the power of Thor right so
like he was possessing for his power and
looking like that's the way it was
originally done all this changed in the
Thor in authority issue number 159 and
what Marvel did is a beibei's basically
came out and said by virtue of Jack
Kirby's tales of Asgard stories and
Stanley writing the writing the Thor
stories is what they said was at some
point in the past
Thor was an actual ddy he's an actual
being that existed out there but was
full of hubris he was full of arrogance
and so because of that Odin wanted to
teach through humility and then in turn
he basically created or crafted the
persona of Donald Blake literally
fabricated this guy out of nowhere and
then wiped all of Thor's memories and
knowledge of who he was and then stuck
his essence inside of Donald Blake and
so as a result of that Donald Blake went
forward believing that he basically
lived his entire life and that he was
channeling the power of Thor and so
following that the two characters were
aware of the others like actual purpose
where they came from that kind of thing
but all that changed again when Walt
Simonson took over Thor with issue
number 337 technically Walt Simonson was
drawing Thor with issue 260 right he
drew issues to 62 to 71 but he took over
is Rider with issue number 337 and with
Donald Lake he snipped that up quick
fast and in a hurry and so what ended up
happening is in in the introduction of
beta ray bill in that comic that what
Odin did is he actually removed the
enchantment of Donald Blake right he
basically said that like Thor and Donald
Blake are no longer the same person at
this kind of you know magical essence
that's being crafted out of nowhere this
Donald Blake persona is gonna be pulled
away from Thor and it's gonna be stuck
inside a beta wave it's a more
Stormbreaker so that Walt Simon can use
it in the future if you wanted to or
anybody else could and so as a result of
that from that point going forward
was no longer associated with Donald
Blake David they had nothing to do with
each other and Thor was always just Thor
and it ran like that for decades right I
ran like that for years and years and
years right up until now and this is why
J michael Straczynski is run is so
important is because it fell in line
with a charter of what it is a joke
asada wanted to do set everything back
to right so everything to the way that
it was supposed to be we just say
setting characters back to the old
school line of thinking and so that's
why these two guys are having this
conversation is because the essence of
Donald Blake is reinstated by this
basically back here again Donald Blake
is his own being out there somewhere
many basically anchors Thor to the real
world right so like it's still like a
singular physical body but it's
basically the essence of Thor the mind
of Thor his spiritual existence more or
less sitting in this void and Donald
Blake is housing the physical body right
so like what will happen is eventually
they'll switch and that's exactly what
takes place this whole conversation that
goes on here is Donald Lake basically
telling telling Thor you have to come
back because if you don't the world will
fall to ruin now in terms of how it is a
Donald Blake knows this that'll be he's
really kind of ambiguous here right and
that was sort of Jay Michaels miscue
saying hey look Lourdes has to come back
and for the most part like it was sort
of hand-wavy it didn't really get off
her a whole lot in the way of an
explanation and fans didn't really care
why Sowinski knew that but for the most
part fans weren't really gonna care how
it is a Donald Blake knew these things
all fans really wanted was for Thor to
come back and this was as good of a
reason as any to basically bring him
back here right and so as a result of
that we're literally Thor says like I
don't want to return because I've seen
what happens in this life that I live
I'm part of the cycle of Ragnarok right
for those are guys who aren't familiar
with that Ragnarok is the the end times
of Asgard right the destruction of
Asgard the difference here is that where
Ragnarok is essentially like the end of
all things for all the Asgardian beings
what Marvel ended up doing was basically
giving us this scenario whereby all the
Asgardian since the very beginning of
all things in existence all as Guardians
have repeatedly died and been reborn as
part of the cycle of Ragnarok seemingly
an unlimited number of times and in fact
Marvel actually came back and they
modified thor issue number 159 which
gave us the reason why it was the thor
was banished to earth as donald lake and
actually tacked on to that and said that
odin did that one of course to teach
Thor humility but to in order to escape
the cycle of Ragnarok it was the one
thing that Odin had never done before he
never cashed Thor down to earth the
cycle of Ragnarok had always gone
through the process of Thor staying on
Asgard and then everything comes to an
end and then everything's reborn again
and so on and so forth
so as a result of that Donald Lakes
responses yeah man but like that's the
nature of things right it's who you are
like you you're a hero you're a savior
like yes you're going to lose people
over the course of your life but it
doesn't take away from the the
achievements that you've made it doesn't
take away for like the great things that
you've done you have to return to Earth
because if you don't then ultimately the
planet is going to fall to ruin and so
as a result of that we're thoris sort of
fighting against these various beings
and various demons to try to keep him
there in the end he ends up summoning
his hammer right the ends up somebody
Mjolnir to himself being more or less
reborn as as Thor and so what this does
is it kind of goes forward from here
right and so essentially what this does
is kind of give us the way Thor always
was right I mean you never really saw it
this way if you look at the old Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby comics but this is
basically how it was it's almost like a
Bruce Banner incredible hawk dichotomy
and so far that Donald Blake is
currently housing the physical form of
the physical body of both four and
Donald Lake he's walking around when the
the stick gets hit on the ground or
whatever it is and and Thor's activated
they switch places right like Thor's
physical essence goes into the body
becomes Donald Blake Donald Blake
actually goes to the void and they kind
of go back and forth as they need to but
of course this leads to - Donald Blake
taking up residence in Broxton Oklahoma
now the reason why he chose Broxton
Oklahoma is because that's where the
hamlet land but it's also the place
where ultimately Thor's gonna start
start making his move and building
everything up right and so the cool
thing about this is that what it does is
it has Donald Blake renting a hotel room
Donald Lake going upstairs into his room
and really for the first time since the
events of Ragnarok and really for the
first time in decades which is a pretty
big deal for a lot of Thor fans Donald
Blake takes a stick
smack [ __ ] on the ground and Thor
returns in his reborn form it's really
cool for people who have been like a fan
of Thor for a very long time or who've
been reading for a really really long
time it was a great return it was a
great reprieve and again that's what
Kassadin Straczynski were looking for
they were looking for this idea of
bringing Thor back in a way to where it
could kind of reinvigorate interest
right it could be like old-school Thor
as you remember him him and Donald Blake
that kind of a thing but with that being
said guys we're gonna go ahead and read
this video to an end if you are new here
- comments explained make sure you guys
at the sub button - become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah let
me know down in the comments section
what you guys think if you guys want me
to continue this and whatnot but let me
know what you guys think and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]